[Musique]
une circonscription au cœur du Sud-Ouest
de Montréal bordé par le canal Lachine
et les voies ferrées Saint Henri
Ste-Anne compte 7 station de métro
bonjour
monsieur ça va bien
droit de prédilection pour faire
campagne pour les 11 candidats qui se
présentent ici à l'élection partielle
la station Charlevoix sur la ligne verte
c'est la porte d'entrée vers le quartier
Pointe Saint-Charles celui que Sarah
Leblanc a choisi pour y élever sa
famille mon mari tanglophone un
immigrant des États-Unis puis on est
vraiment tombé amoureux avec le
Sud-Ouest parce que c'était comme un peu
le meilleur des deux mondes pour nous
comme ailleurs à Montréal
lambourgeoisement côtoie la pauvreté
peut-être que je suis naïve parce que je
me sens peut-être un petit peu comme si
je faisais partie du problème la
gentrification mais je sens quand même
qu'il y ait vraiment belle cohabitation
en tout ce monde là tous beau monde là
il y a vraiment un esprit communautaire
d'un point de Saint-Charles les
commerces de proximité ont poussé mais
le milieu communautaire restant créé
comme à l'épicerie autogéré le détour
néanmoins le quartier a beaucoup changé
parlez-en à Louise Tremblay qui habite
le coin depuis 22 ans
ça se donnait parce que personne voulait
habiter le quartier c'était quand même
encore tof
[Musique]
criminalité drogue prostitution Pointe
Saint-Charles étaient loin d'être prisée
comme aujourd'hui des jeunes familles
ont commencé à acheter à transformer des
duplexes en unif familiale il commence
juste à y avoir un petit peu de
restriction à ce niveau là
les prix ont explosé les loyers ne cesse
d'augmenter bref les problèmes d'abord
d'habilité se sont multipliés l'enjeu
c'est le logement c'est clair c'est
clair c'est ça la grosse problématique
parce que les gens sont évacés il y a
pas moyen de seuer ici convenablement à
prix abordable le candidat de la CAQ le
sang bien c'est important de les aider
un budget qui s'en vient c'est pas un
point qui est un député caquiste dans le
passé mais moi c'est justement j'aime ça
aller sur le terrain présenter mon
message quand la véritable bataille ici
se livre entre Québec solidaire et le
Parti libéral du Québec
pour conserver ce fief libéral le PLQ
mobilise c'est trop partout
historiquement toujours été libéral on
ne prend personne pour acquis et on
travaille très très fort il faut faire
sortir le vote et ce qui est génial
c'est que quand on va voir les gens ils
s'engagent d'aller de sortir voter parce
qu'il réalise ok c'est important on est
en train de choisir notre prochain
députés à 79 ans les Simone
nous plein a vu des libéraux se
succédaient ici il y a eu une école
loisirs mais on parle de loin le départ
de Dominique Anglade lui a fait beaucoup
de peine mais elle va continuer de voter
rouge même si cette fois elle ne connaît
ni le candidat ni le chef vous
connaissez pas le chef par intérieur non
on va apprendre de vivre
merci beaucoup pour Guillaume cléryver
c'est un match revanche après avoir
perdu par 2700 voix en octobre dernier
il y allait avoir une partiel donc on a
vraiment continué notre terrain on n'a
jamais arrêté Québec solidaire mise sur
le renouvellement de l'électorat pour
renforcer ses assises à Montréal c'est
une élection qui est importante parce
qu'on vient de l'emporter juste à côté
d'ici dans Verdun donc on veut
consolider nos gains à Montréal je pense
que ça va nous rendre plus fort ça
ensuite
mais comme à chaque élection partielle
le plus grand défi c'est de convaincre
les électeurs de se rendre aux urbes ici
jacauderie Charbonneau Radio-Canada dans
la circonscription c'est Henri 5 ans